so I I don't want to freak anyone else  but I think we just made a Star Wars  movie actually I just have one goal  which is to make the most powerful Star  Wars movie I possibly can  once we decided that we were making Star  Wars movies he was one of the people  that I was immediately interested in I  looked into his eyes and I saw conflict  you have to lay down all your chips in  front of a lot of really good poker  players I trust him  I have to trust him feels really nice to  put Luke Skywalker in front of a camera  I think he's just beginning to dawn the  sheer scope of this project which is  enormous it's really house of cards  everything needs to be like so perfect  you know to get it done I got really  scared every single decision is personal  to him the best shot at making something  good is to come into it and trust my  guts you know I love Star Wars the last  Jedi is yours to own on digital in  blu-ray  you